as you've repeated several times now
you're not even a huge trump supporter
and yet you're you are put in a position
where you have to defend some of these
ideals I'm not a trump supporter and I
feel the same way if I want to stand up
for the ideals that I stand for I have
to call this nonsense out because
apparently no one in the medial do it
you know there's another great example
of that did you see a couple weeks ago
when that guy tried to bum rush Trump on
stage and then the next night he was on
CNN and all the news channels and they
were treating him as if he was some
legit voice of counter protest but
meanwhile he was trying to attack a
presidential candidate whether you like
Trump or not right so this is this is
fully the fault of the media here right
well exactly I mean you flip around if a
right winger tried to attack Bernie
Sanders or Hillary Clinton but he
wouldn't be on CNN the next day being
given a complimentary welcoming platform
yet we see this again and again and you
know Trump is the creation of social
justice worries at the end of the day
every action has an equal and opposite
reaction and people are just tired
they're tired of being lectured about
how racist they are they're tired about
being lectured to check their privilege
and whether you agree with Trump or not
I don't agree with him on things like
torture or surveillance but this is the
backlash you know these people who
support from a so condescended towards
by the mainstream media but they had to
work for everything they had these are
mainly quite poor blue-collar workers
that are supporting Trump but they're
sick of being made to feel guilty about
who they are but the establishment still
doesn't recognize that fact and just
labels them racists and bigots they
still don't get it they still don't get
what's driving this phenomenon and it
might end up you know slapping them in
the face yeah well I think it's slapping
them in the face right now so how much
of this do you think is establishment
politicians and just the establishment
on both the Democrats and the
Republicans in bed with the media that
they've all gotten so fat for so long
that they've all just asked terrible
questions and no good follow-ups and
they've all just been in this game
for so long that they their fear of
Trump is that he's gonna leave a lot of
these guys without a job a lot of these
pundits on TV and all these people who
have professionally gotten everything
wrong for years but they've had a gig
and a lot of these people I think think
well I'm not gonna have a gig if Trump
gets in so they're they're protecting
their own asses more than anything else
well that's definitely part of it I mean
the other part is you know Trump is
self-funded he's a maverick he might be
a rich bigoted buffoon but he's
unpredictable and the elite the
establishment the political
establishment is used to having not one
but two candidates in every single
presidential race that they control I
mean go back to 2004 you know Bush and
Kerry both skullenbones members that's
you know that's business as usual for
the political elite somebody like Trump
comes along he's a he's a loose cannon
he's unpredictable they don't know what
he's gonna do I think if he got in power
he would immediately start you know
moderating his rhetoric or whatever but
they're scared stiff because it's simply
an unknown quantity and as he said a lot
of you know people in the establishment
who have relied on this status quo for
so long for decades are now petrified
because you know he's come along and
upturned the applecart people are scared
yeah so do you view this all as just a
big negotiating ploy with him because
you know I was seeing this week he made
this comment that you know maybe Japan
should have nukes and everyone is saying
well then he's gonna start a nuclear
arms race but what he really was saying
was either Japan should be able to
defend itself with nukes because North
Korea is there and China and everything
else or they should pay us to defend
them meaning pay the United States
because we basically have agreements
that we defend them militarily so it's
not that crazy of a proposal that we
should be paid you you know if you were
celebrity you pay your bodyguard right
so do you think a lot of this is that he
just throws this stuff out there then
gets misquoted you know what I mean the
media runs or they die he wants to start
a nuclear arms race and then people it
even strengthens him more because then
people go wait a minute that wasn't that
crazy of a proposal now they just run
the banner headline that suits their
agenda as he said if you actually drill
down into what he's saying sometimes it
makes a lot of sense sometimes he just
missed speaks entirely I mean back a few
months ago him advocates at bringing in
Syrian refugees then within 24 hours
completely reversed his position so it's
partly that but geopolitically from a
geopolitical standpoint Trump is better
than anyone else and definitely Hillary
Clinton I mean they called Trump
Islamophobic he's not the one who voted
for a war that killed a million Muslims
you know he's not the one that supported
regime change in Syria and Libya that
led to this migrant crisis in the first
place Hillary Clinton did he's not the
one who's amping up for World War three
with Russia as every other single GOP
candidate has during the debates so if
you want to talk I mean all this
rhetoric about you know Trump's the
world's gonna explode the day Trump gets
into office because he's so crazy and
out of control if you actually look at
his prior record and what he's
advocating in terms of America's
military role in the world it's the most
peaceful definitely out of all the GOP
candidates indefinitely over and above
Hillary Clinton who voted for the Iraq
war you know it's funny I was at a very
liberal progressive LA party this
weekend and people were freaking out
over Trump and I kept trying to say to
them guys if you fear Trump if you're a
liberal or a progressive or anyone on
the left you should fear Ted Cruz far
more than you fear Donald Trump but I
couldn't get people to quite understand
why and I'm sort of amazed by that well
it's because they don't read I mean
that's that's my guess
they don't read beyond headlines and if
you actually listen to Trump speeches
which you know he rambles on for an hour
or so but if you actually listen to most
of them most of his speech is devoted to
things like trade deals I mean this is
why people are voting for it
it's a reaction you know to the lost
jobs to the ruined towns in middle
America because of NAFTA because of
these trade deals that have screwed them
over
if you map his supporters it correlates
almost directly with the industry
deindustrialization and despair these
areas of America that have been
completely abandoned completely left to
rot by these trade deals that have
resulted in the great sucking sound of
these jobs leaving America so you know
watch his speeches they a liberal a
progressive will never watch his
speeches it's not mainly about building
the wall it's not mainly about banning
Muslims it's mainly about trade and
that's why he has a lot of support monks
blue-collar workers because people's
jobs have been shipped abroad and
they're furious about it and that's
mainly a left-wing position to be
complaining about that has been in the
past so it's interesting that most
liberals just aren't aware of the main
body of his actual speech and why people
are attracted to his campaign well
that's like when you know they'll tweet
out they'll say oh look Trump ties are
made in Mexico and they say oh what a
hypocrite he is but that doesn't prove
he's a hypocrite that shows he's a good
businessman he's used our shitty trade
deals that our politicians have signed
to make money here and he's saying I
will change those deals so people like
me won't have to do that somehow that's
lost on all my liberal friends no matter
how many times I bring that up exactly
and also what's lost on them and if you
look at the lines of people going to
these Trump events which again we've had
reports in Wisconsin this week you know
a lot of asian-americans quite a few
black people in fact back when Rubio was
in the race Trump had more than double
the support from Muslim Americans than
every other GOP candidate combined he
set to break records for black votes of
support for a Republican candidate so
again this narrative that it's just
about bigotry and racism is just surface
crap you delve a little bit below and
you have to understand the wider
phenomenon why he has this support this
is about a complete political revolution
this is about an overthrow of the status
quo Americans are sick of it and now
finally they're putting their vote
behind it whether it be for Trump or
Sanders yeah so let's move away from
Trump a little bit I want to back up to
something you said about
so Hillary in your eyes because of
obviously all the connections between
her husband and the establishment
connections that she's been involved in
this forever from being a first lady to
a senator or Secretary of State and all
that she's absolutely who the
establishment wants right do you see any
wiggle room on that oh now why the
establishment behind Hillary 100% I mean
I went to build a burg in it was Denmark
in 2014 Austria 2015 and even back then
we got the inside leaked from the
Bilderberg Group meeting which is this
conference of 120 influential bankers
politicians academics and even back then
they they had come together and said
Hillary's our pick for 2060 my gonna try
and defund all her competition so years
back Hillary was their pick I mean in
2008 she took the fall for Obama and
that was decided it's a meeting in
Chantilly coincidentally the same
location where the Bilderberg meeting
was taking place back in 2018 so yeah
Hillary's being a shoo-in for a long
time now for the elite so where does
this put Sanders in your mind because
look he wants a lot of the changes you
know ironically Sanders and Trump are
talking about a lot of the same stuff
right they both want to severely change
the power structure change the system
yet their supporters seem to absolutely
hate each other so I suspect you agree
with some of the heart of Sanders just
not the policy I can't bring myself to
agree with somebody who says that red
lines aren't necessarily a bad thing I
mean this idea that Bernie Sanders
supports us if he loses to Hillary which
looks like it's almost certainly gonna
happen are then gonna go and vote for
Trump because he's the other
anti-establishment option I just don't
buy that because for the very reason you
just said they absolutely hate each
other I don't think many of Bernie
Sanders supporters really jive with his
anti-establishment cred I think they
jive more with this extreme left-wing
social justice warrior Pro socialist Pro
massive welfare state position which I
can't bring
myself to agree with but just from the
behavior of his supporters over the past
couple of months has really turned me
off to anything that Bernie Sanders
stands for unfortunately yeah you know
it's really interesting I don't know
that I've ever felt this way about a
candidate and I don't even know that I
could have made this up but I like him
more than I like the reasons that people
are supporting him I think this is what
I was telling my innopolis a couple
weeks ago I think he himself is a decent
guy whether I disagree with him or not
but the underpinnings of what he's
bringing I think are really dangerous
and that's what I fear and that's a
strange place to feel about a candidate
when you like them but you don't like
what they're sort of bringing along with
them I don't know that I've ever felt
that way before about somebody well no
and it's for the same reason that the
Trump phenomenon has happened I mean
he's not you can't control him he's a
maverick he's unpredictable they
wouldn't be able to buy him off so
whatever his policies which I
fundamentally disagree with he still
represents the threats of the
establishment because he's an unknown
quantity so I mean that's that's why
Sanders has paralleled the Trump
phenomenon but you know as it the way it
looks now he's basically got no chance
so it remains to be seen what's gonna
happen to his voters but I very much
doubt they're gonna go over to Trump in
the kind of numbers that people are
suggesting right so with the Sanders
people my sense is that a lot of them
really want to just burn the system down
and that's sort of why I can't get
behind them because yeah we have a lot
of problems in America we've done bad
things internationally you there's too
much money in politics we need a fairer
economic system or all kinds of stuff
that I can get on board with the ideas
of what he says but there's still
something pretty good here in America
and I think we forget that as Americans
and that's what I fear is that these
people want to actually burn the system
down and I'm afraid if you burn it down
what rises out of those ashes is not
gonna be any better or at least the
chances of it being any better are not
very good
well when his supporters are carrying
around hammer and sickle communist flags
and talking about a socialist revolution
I mean that gives me the jitters I mean
can look at Sanders personally you know
he didn't have a job until he was 40
years old he was basically a bomb living
on the the floors of other people's upon
so his personal lifestyle kind of turns
me off towards him as well whereas he
said the kind of things his supporters
advocate are in many cases a lot worse
than what he's advocating so they want
to tear the system down but they
basically want to replace it with
outright communism a lot of them and
again it goes back to this you know
resist capitalism hashtag that was on
Twitter a couple of months ago these
people are you know they're probably
aged what twenty to thirty they've got
no idea whatsoever of the absolute
horror that communism has wrought on the
world over the last 50 60 years and we
keep having to you know have that debate
over and over again of why communism is
bad and why leaving people to their own
devices and building a free-market
economy is good because there's this
fundamental ignorant surrounding
capitalism people think that the system
of capitalism we've got now is
free-market capitalism it isn't it's
corporatism right crony capitalism but
they think that that's free-market
capitalism which is why they go to the
extreme other end of the equation and
think that communism is the solution
when history has proven that it's not we
keep having to recycle that argument
over and over again because a lot of
these Millennials just you know don't
know the history right so instead of
detangling some of the crony capitalism
and some of the Wall Street money and
all that stuff which he talks about
which is extremely legit they go we're
gonna burn the whole thing down we're
gonna become communist which is crazy